[Musique]
elle ne vous a pas demandé les installations de HBO en
Yakoutie, comme d'habitude, aucun mois de miracles propres et
sobres n'est possible, madame, ce que
vous faites pour être le nain le plus célèbre du
monde, l'homme avec le Golden Gun Fantasy
Island
[Musique]
pensez que vous pouvez  gérer que
c'est ce que vous montrez superflux sur HBO je
n'ai pas donné d'interview et Daniele
moi d'autre Tony Blair Jr quelle est
votre histoire juste parce que je suis un petit
ne signifie pas qu'il doit être actif je
comprends quoi  Je dois être
peut être de grands sourires tout le monde étant dans
cette émission c'est comme gagner à la loterie
dites-moi ce que c'était que d'être célèbre
maman vous ne vous souvenez tout simplement pas à quel point
le ciel est mauvais
l'épreuve de force doit faire du
bien de penser que tu es meilleur que
tout le monde seulement vu la vie dure
tu sais pas c'est quoi t'es mes profs
junior Lille pour le bâton mais vois pour
le bâton tu n'en fais pas pour moi
[Musique]
produire peut être un  pic le contact le moins soudé
en Amérique et ce sera une histoire
ouais ce serait certainement Je m'en fous de tout
ce qui vous a fait savoir que c'était L le citoyen Joe dans le besoin
LSU HBO
vous